thank you
[Music]
didn't you want to ask me why I was
Japanese welcome back to another amazing
episode of the careful boys we are
currently off the Record and we have
Jason Cheney back in the building
given the people what they want man I'm
a big fan of you what happened last time
when bar had all the [ __ ] military
school stories and then you're like I
don't know what you're talking about I
never said that yeah you did I never
said I don't know why like I don't
remember I don't remember anything and
then [ __ ] at home you [ __ ] texted
me all day look at all these pictures
dude this guy was a [ __ ] stud dude
this is my brother starts texting me I'm
not a this will start texting all kinds
of pictures I didn't say I wanted to it
didn't have enough time
we had 20 minutes bro I got [ __ ]
talking about seats for this [ __ ]
pleading the fifth we're trying not to
sing he doesn't have your name were you
just not as comfortable with this group
yet
can I tell you can I tell you guys
something no what there's too many
questions at once and I can't answer all
the time answer quick one answer for all
the questions okay when it um I didn't
have enough time okay I have so much to
say okay okay this is here's why you're
back and I quote this is what you're
texting me Bart I just watched the new
episode with you talking about a a which
is Army Navy Academy I know you're super
busy with multiple stuff but can we
please find time to share any
experiences
[Laughter]
it'll be fun wait and then this is what
I wrote I wrote that's what I was trying
to say on camera last time yeah but you
were saying some stuff I didn't want to
be like hey this is my stuff I want to
hear you you're the guest I want to hear
your stuff we should spend time arguing
instead of telling the stories
and I said because AMA is a crazy place
with a lot of insane stuff goes down
there and you said all this [ __ ] all the
[ __ ] you said was some real [ __ ] it was
it was for sure like prison LOL just no
grapes I think no grape you say without
the G without the G huh you can't say
the other word grapes without the G is
no Ray pegs
Apes yes yeah you're right but did you
feel did he send me pictures too look at
them did you feel left wow
did you feel like he didn't really back
you up in this where you were like man
I'm telling stories and he's all I don't
know did he make you feel like a monster
well it's because like it's what you
sounded like the military so one
99 of people you know don't ever go to a
boarding school that's true true well my
brother went to a boarding school yeah
like most people live with 50 of the
people you know go to boys what are the
lower ones most people live with their
parents right in America it's very
normal it's actually not normal to like
in junior high you don't live with their
parents anymore that's really weird
that's true and then you go to a
military
boarding school it is not even that much
smaller oh that's small and then you go
two random Asians that didn't know each
other that end up going to a military
school that are on YouTube now it's
[ __ ] crazy I was like dude the
experiences are insane and uh she's
trying to connect with me I tell people
a lot of the [ __ ] sounds made up but
this guy's been there so I'm trying to
get him to like corroborate your stories
I'm like you you were at the Raper Nan
King as me why are we you know why why
are you going why are you doing eyebrows
why are you going no I wasn't there I
was in Shanghai I know I was I was there
what see what are you trying to say now
huh what I was trying to say the right
thing okay
now you have time tell us your story
Jason no but why this is so much
pressure now
I just thought he would share some stuff
and I go yeah that's the thing so last
time okay and then I say
I say cheers
you're gonna go through each one of them
and explain yourself can we okay let's
let's put those pictures up so the fans
can see while we're talking about this
yeah okay okay I just want to also
explain this to people because I didn't
know how the you know Vibe is and I
didn't know what you want to go with we
don't give a [ __ ] okay I didn't know
this can't you tell we aggressively do
not care okay
yeah we care that you care too much yeah
if it wasn't for the algorithm I'll say
even crazier [ __ ] dude nothing matters
anymore what's an algorithm oh [ __ ]
the Algos
we just don't want the the Bot police to
take down this video this by the way is
like the most passionate Bart's been in
a video in like three months he's
usually asleep
he's about to turn the camera off he
woke up for you dude yeah pretty much if
you could just be real that's not so
nice you totally have time I really be
real to do what go through the picture I
was gonna do it right now but the part
but the phone is off now
because Anthony was [ __ ] being my Pro
office doing a lot of passing the blame
and not taking accountability all right
you go go now Anthony you be quiet all
right all right
so this
explain yourself okay so this picture is
when I
um first went in and I cutie dude and I
was accepting my sentence how old are
you I think this is 13 or 14. dang dude
did everyone have to shave their head
yeah in the first day were you even
there I forgot yeah I haven't been there
yeah on the first day you're not even
cooperating your story what's up
you're supposed to go yeah that's true I
remember thank you I remember everybody
he arrived with a shave head already
honestly probably I think wait did you
learn a bit they're like you got to grow
it a little bit more so honestly I kind
of forgot wait did you not have pictures
I do oh I didn't bring them okay okay
that would have been cool that's why I'm
like I don't know if if I should say my
stuff because bro talk more about your
stories okay and then I found rats in a
soup one time at the mess hall the first
week rats in the soup one rats one one
rat one rat yep
he's also your grammar police in
addition I just want to confirm the
story it's been solo we've been so
excited about you coming back yeah man
one raps it was red rat and then inside
there's more Rats on the inside
so one rats [ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] ratsu
it's a pregnant rat yeah okay so just to
kind of give you guys like a visual
the mess hall is kind of like a HomeTown
Buffet where you walk in it was it the
same way when you went there where all
the food when you walk in it's all on
the left oh they'll be left yeah so you
just take whatever yeah this is thing
that would do with the HomeTown Buffet
so in in the lunch time they'll go ready
for some burgers and then they'll have
they'll announce it they'll ring the
bell and everything
guys ready for some burgers
[Laughter]
that sounds like the school's a Dream
It's a fat man scoop went there yeah I
don't know what you guys are complaining
about all the time
okay nobody say that I just I'm just
trying to preface what's going on that's
the best though okay so there's no DJ
you got it got it no DJ yeah one rat
snuggy someone goes you got a 20 Bill
put your hands up
[Music]
so that lady comes out ready for some
burgers right and then they'll put the
patties and the the bread right make
your own Burger you but you say it you
go can I have a burger you know no
lettuce you know what I lied you you get
your own Burger okay cool all right yeah
so let's go on to the more important
part of the story okay
that's my truth
watermelon keep derailing Jason is my
point oh yeah oh
I want to know the watermelon no no no
you don't want to know
for lunch there's burgers and then as a
as a person who just got in you're not
supposed to drink
uh soft drinks
I don't you only can have water right
like you have to earn your right yeah
you have to earn oh yeah I forgot holy
[ __ ] what's that crisis so it has soda
available but you had you can yeah it's
like HomeTown Buffet right like you go
like yeah but you can't drink it unless
like if the [ __ ] instructor sees that
[ __ ] you're in trouble like like what
the [ __ ] that coke in your cup yeah
wow yeah yeah but it's diet but they
teach you the hard way nobody says it
until you do it the wrong way yeah
exactly nobody's like you can't handle
good I see yeah and then um but then
this is what they would do is that I
night time they go is everybody ready
for
meatballs pasta
okay
no no because of the thing is they it's
it's the meat from the lunch time and
then you know so it is like that and
then the next day they go is anybody
ready for meatball soup
and then the night time they go is
anybody for ready for
um Burger La Pasta
for the burgers ground beef leftover
yeah yeah for sure it is it's for the
pasta and then the next next it's a soup
they recycle as long as they could but
where are the rats coming up so okay so
about five minutes has passed is this
the most exciting thing you've got I'm
just wondering no and then the rat came
when did you find the rats in the
fuzzles not it wasn't my soup it was my
friend's soup they go it was like oh
what is this and I'm like oh no it's
just a chicken noodle soup and then uh
he poked it and the head slid out like
this on the bowl it was like this hello
I was like ew dude and then I keep
drinking my soup
even though it's from the same bat yeah
yeah yeah holy [ __ ] yeah I remember this
was and and we would like break into
um the mess hall at night time because
it was an Excursion like oh damn you
guys broke in yeah like what do you what
should we do at night like a genius and
then we're broken and then alarm because
I was just starving dude so like when
you live here every every room you have
a roommate right and then you have like
a Foot Locker you could keep some of
your [ __ ] if you got nice parents they
might send you some snacks instant
noodles everyone has a water boiler in
the Foot Locker so they're trying to
like make food at night because they
don't give enough food yeah and uh the
the Rowdy ones would be like well let's
[ __ ] skip campus and there's a
7-Eleven down the street and then you
would have to try to like somehow
finesse yourself some regular clothes so
you don't have a screaming military
uniform in the middle of the city so you
have to like blend in right even though
you have a military haircut they all
knew though they probably knew yeah they
probably see a bunch of like shape had
kids come in they just oh [ __ ] these
guys ditch school again yeah so it's
hard to like really assimilate for some
reason never crossed my mind to just
break into the mess hall which is where
all the food is stored you're busy
breaking faces no you know what the
bullying was for real though which
bowling
huh huh
wait wait wait you put at me like I
bullied you yeah man why'd you do this
to me wait wait you you broke into the
mess hall and the alarm went off yeah so
we all broke into the
um thank you Joe for getting us back on
track and then I'm gonna tell you
something the
um we saw rats in the mess hall and the
Rats was this big and they were eating
like
yeah I think it was a possum it was like
a like a a farm rat and then I was we
were so scared and then we ran out and
with the alarm
and then the [ __ ] rat was like what
are you doing here yeah what are you
doing go away you know it's our turn to
eat now did you get any of the food and
you could bring any cookies back no
would you we were so nervous and we just
you know what I mean and then we just uh
[ __ ] around in the thing and then that's
how hungry you guys were but it was an
Excursion no it wasn't a hunger thing it
was just like for fun yeah what should
we do you guys didn't get in trouble we
did some bullets we're doing it for fun
and we didn't know we wouldn't bring
that backed in here
how did you get caught when the alarm
went off you ran back then we ran back
they knew they I think they had um yeah
cameras Oh wow and everything they knew
like cigarettes or
and they I remember they had parades do
you remember they have parades yeah like
we had to do that people hated that I
said you know he's only talking about
the darkness of his history you're
talking about a lot of fun never
mentioned parades parades okay but
because I was gonna say I wasn't a dude
that bullying thing and then he and then
you came back with the mess also yeah
what's the bullying I want to say one
more thing about the parade thing
because I remember people hated it so
much am I running the time I'm sorry no
no why would you guys do parades because
they wanted they had to Pride of the
town and they would do it like how often
you guys did Pride parades so there's
like a drill team like I see military
price so you guys who do the March for
the parade would you be in the parade
for the pride parade we all did so what
did you have to do in the parade I was
in band one time and don't get mad at me
don't yell at me because I don't know
what the [ __ ] the parade is
right well the way you asked the
question was a little aggressive yeah
yeah you're right you're right hello
so what would you do in the parade which
is March you're just marching you're
just [ __ ] walking down the street
yeah but you have to stand there in the
sun marching the Sun for like the whole
day and we hate it everybody hated it
but people hated it so much that they're
just people who the only way you get out
of the parade is that if you were hurt
and I remember a guy will hold on to a
bench and then have somebody break their
arm so that they don't have to go to
them that's how much they didn't want to
do this but I would not do this
just for the parade and this guy with
the broom would try to hit his arm as
hard as possible so many times and he's
just like and then I remember and then
he didn't have to go but then he had a
cast on for like a whole for like a
whole whole week because but because
we're really bored so like that [ __ ] so
that school is like mini jail right like
in jail people are down to stuff cell
phones and guns and they're [ __ ]
right and this is something that's like
43. yeah at this school you have a lot
of jail like Tendencies because it's
still the same mechanisms of thinking
but even uh less inhibitions because
you're [ __ ] kids oh okay so when your
kids trying to do kid [ __ ] with zero
adult supervision but you still have the
same amount of creativity you have like
[ __ ] like that wow yeah it's like it's
he's like I'd rather break my arm than
to March in the parade with a [ __ ]
Flag doing this [ __ ] just like the guy
that's doubt more down to stuff a gun up
his ass rather than like be at home and
be a father to his kid yeah yeah
what uh um what kind of do you have to
play an instrument like a band so in the
beginning I really wanted to do um being
a drill team because everybody was so
cool like with the rifles the rifles the
rifles oh because and they're like the
back they're like so cool and yeah I
wanted to be that because if you get
like a chord or whatever you have to get
jumped to get the cord and I was like I
want to get jumped because I feel like
that was like an honor is the chord the
thing that goes yeah the red one so they
they it was it a part of the school like
they'll beat your ass the principles
just get your ass congratulations Jason
we knew you could do it well yeah with
this the uh platoon Sergeant or the the
platoon leader who's [ __ ] 15 years
old
a reasonable leader was yeah would you
know but um but I really wanted that and
and it was nice to get
I I would it's really nice to get
punched because well because I gotta
finish when I'm finished because you I
feel like oh
he likes me like my father
okay I'm worth it it was worth it it was
worth it got it he honestly like my
father book of approval yeah yeah did
you get it deep and fun yeah at the same
time just one time oh you have a picture
show that picture oh yeah picture
picture there's there was one that shows
the Accord that you got right or no oh
no I didn't get a chord I just I never
got one just got put it shorter or the
part of the game
boxer Brigade oh no way that's him being
the drill team barbell brief game so you
got into drill team though yeah I did
get in yeah oh yeah you don't look as
cool when you don't have a cord so so
when you marched in a parade when you
marched in a parade you did the gun yeah
I did it and you spin it and stuff yeah
what did you do that before you got the
gun did you do
or you just [ __ ] marched everyone
everybody gets it's a toy gun everybody
yeah everybody gets it so when you do
the March everyone gets the the barrels
like filled with cement or whatever
steel so you can't oh shoot it's a heavy
gun it's not really heavy but it's just
filled it's it's uh wait we're almost
out of time what about the bullies out
of commission the bullet um there's so
many things with the bully thing is I
think that's a separate one huh what do
you think hey let it let it roll let it
run over and let it run over you know no
not bad I wanted to run it over we could
just walk over here I'm like this is
Juicy stuff we need a whole another 20
minutes oh yeah right here
the bully stuff stop pointing at me dude
he just he pointed at you so I wanna no
he wants to meet corroborate I want him
to authentically be inspired by his past
we both got bullied at the same time
what's going on you know what
no you didn't what what grade did you
get in though what grade was so this is
uh this is why I had to spend five years
in high school
to get it why do you have to do some
people have to to get a masters you went
five years too maybe because then at
this school you can't come in as a
senior
because you have so much military
tradition you can't just come in as a
senior you have to come in and relearn
it oh so you're supposed to be a senior
I know so when I left keppel I left
keppel as a Jew bro that's why you
beating people up bro you're the senior
seniors beat everybody up bro I was
supposed I came in as an eighth grade
the scum of the sky
no soda allowed so I was a seniors get
to drink sodas immediately supposed to
be a senior but I couldn't be a senior
yeah so you're a junior so it was my
second junior year dude that's the
baddest of the best dude like this guy's
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] and he's strong
and he's strong bro you get respect
immediately you know what's crazy this
is how many delinquents are at this
school it's actually very normal to find
seniors that are 19 and 20 years old
yeah that's very true probably [ __ ] dude
that's how [ __ ] up you got like 13
year olds with [ __ ] 20 years like 21
Jump Street military if you look at the
yearbook everybody looks 35. like
you came in when you were 13 years old
yeah how old were you when you came in
probably 16 or 17. yeah but then it's
like you if you go back to the the
yearbook they look so much older like I
look at my I'm like man this guy is like
yeah 20 to 13 is is a whole [ __ ]
decade it's crazy yeah everybody seniors
will beat everybody up are you kidding
me I remember this I remember this
junior this dude
um his name is just two is uh Bart and a
Bart and Burke and board
I like board the guys that beat you up
they weren't Asian though right they're
black oh you guys stop I gotta stop and
say it like that because so this is this
is a look in the left but I love they're
really nice people now though because
this is the similarity between that
place in jail where everyone's clicked
up by race yeah and so ever so there's
gangs in there too so there's like white
gangs black gangs Asian Games whatever
so everyone that's clicked up
um you really protect their own
okay you know what I mean so all the
fights I had with people yeah were all
non-asians and it probably started with
them [ __ ] with one of my youngsters
and then I hear about it and then so I
have to go regulate but I'll hear from
you Hispanic black or whatever I'm like
what the [ __ ] so you backed him up so he
was your youngster more than likely yeah
if we were there at the same time that
would be really nice you got Pierre
respects
all right
that's it
um that would be really nice I would
have loved that
that if you're like going to buy the
opportunity if you had your own Bart
because if I have my own bar that would
be really nice because the thing is when
I was there the Taiwanese group trying
to win these Chinese group they weren't
really strong when I was there there
weren't like it was always the Korean
because he already graduated he already
graduated but the Koreans and the
Chinese all hung out too that we did but
the Koreans and the Japanese was the
strongest the the best fighter in this
school the best was the Japanese guy
everybody scared was scared of him
because he like did like a flying
headlock
dude what is that no with his foot
yeah karate or something what the [ __ ]
and then he would be is it like this
this is the stuff Legends are made of
dude we gotta find this
and people like did you see that [ __ ]
and everybody was everybody was scared
of them the legend Man flying headlock
like rat soup
that's the name of the movie dude his
experience was vastly different from
your experience no no but sounds like he
lived a lot I got
like the people were bully did this what
they would do I remember my roommates he
would sit on my face
and then he will slap me like this for
like what's he win 15 minutes wait if
he's sitting on your face what's he
slapping like my chest
that sounds like some white boy [ __ ] was
he white no he was like but is he
punking in for reals or is he showing
you like love no that time Dad specific
was talking to me for real but it wasn't
like what did you do and then there's
another time because what did you do
that
I was just like stop
he was my roommate he was a junior I was
in eighth grade he was like my platoon
Sergeant oh okay but there was love
after though he showed me like 50 Cent
you know and I was like he said
I know he said in your face but check
this out Get Rich or Die try it all
right this is the best album ever dude
that's the part that's scary like the
person you're you're ruined with yeah
technically like you're silly almost
would be like they could have their way
with you the whole the whole [ __ ]
night if they wanted to yeah exactly but
then he didn't scream or cry her no not
that because I was always like the goofy
one that people were like okay he's a
goofy [ __ ] I always try to make him
laugh what do you mean by [ __ ] huh what
damn that's crazy man but um
but yeah but after the Koreans I I was
really sad because people would keep on
bullying me and they would keep showing
you 50 Cent every time
a new artist afterwards yeah that's how
he learns about hip-hop in general
you can [ __ ] this kid just show him some
hip-hop then he'll be happy here's Fat
Joe
they're just running out of all right
here's some independent dude we're
running out bro he has a big hip-hop
Library
hahaha
I did but um but after I had to so the
Koreans they're really strong too and
then they will go like man because
they're really strong and people
respected them and I go man I I would
want to be strong too and then I go to
the gym and then I remember this guy his
name is Teja he would um he's like the
strongest Korean guy and then he would
tell us to go he'll be like hey I will
teach you guys how to fight and then we
will wear gloves and he would just beat
us up
and I go yeah man this is good it's
Classic this is good that's exactly the
[ __ ]
but then the thing is he like
but it was like four of us it would just
get beat up by these two Koreans
and then we'll go Yep this is nice
because then we're learning how to fight
dude why do they always do dude they
always do that why you think Koreans are
number one Asian no but because no no
because at that at that time when my
experience because nobody stood up for
other Asians and only they stood up
before uh KP baby if that was me I think
Koreans are number one as well at the
time at that school obviously not
anymore you don't think what happened to
Japanese uh
what happened
and they just take care of themselves
nobody they don't care about they don't
care about anybody and then also yeah
that's what I'm saying don't give a [ __ ]
about they just come and punch people
and you know and it's not my cake people
and we're just trying to kick people or
just take it and then we go ha ha ha
good times
like that it's like it's imagine a place
like if we're walking in a hallway
I could just come and just push Nick
like off a balcony and literally
nothing's gonna happen
ran by kids it's round by kids or some
adults a lot of the fly [ __ ] there's
this wand remember the senior lawn yeah
yeah there's this grass patch area that
nobody could step on it and if you step
on it you get punched and then seniors
will push people into the line and go
look at that and then people would just
[ __ ] them up wow yeah yeah yeah and then
the urge to want to pass that on is so
high for those people if it happened to
you because it happened to them I see I
couldn't wait to be a senior so you
bullied other people I couldn't wait but
and then I left that 10th grade oh you
did oh you never got your chance so you
only went through the [ __ ] years yeah
damn and I couldn't wait to do but then
when I was in 10th Grade I didn't want
to do stuff today eighth grade you
wanted to be a good example no oh but I
just was busy like [ __ ] off instead
of like smoke stuck over that cigarettes
and uh drink a little bit and
um have a good time yeah you got
sidetracked laughs